George you appeared I believe in the
London company of the of the film and
what part were you playing
you were playing riff right yes sir it
was playing it excuse me her her
Majesty's Theatre in London and I was
playing riff I did it for a year and a
half before I got to do the film after
being in the stage show in London and
then coming to West Side Story with
Robert Wise and Jerome Robbins and
multimers and all this what was the big
shift in your head as far as adjusting
to the film version of it well and you
put in a different royalty the big ships
I suppose of people often asked me about
it was playing bernardo rather than then
riff and sometimes people ask me if that
was a hard kind of move to makin and it
wasn't at all and the thing that i one
of the things that I attribute that to
is doing the show in London you are in
the first riff and Bernardo in the play
are dead at the end of the first act so
the second act we've got nothing to do
and if there was but it's not in the
movie um so but you know the loudspeaker
is on all the time and you hear
everything is going onstage constantly
so with a kind of osmosis suppose you
become so familiar without trying to
become familiar with everything about
the theatre everybody's part how they
came in how they spoke how they sounded
injuries direction and all of that so
when I got the call it was actually was
a letter from United Artists who say
they wanted to test me for the film and
they asked me to do a scene as riff and
a scene as Bernardo a few of us in the
company did that and they took us out to
Shepperton studios outside of London and
in the course of the day we all did our
respective tests and it all felt so
great and so then we drove back to the
show to do theatre do the show that
night and then we'd ask each other in
the weeks that came passing each other
all have you heard anything have you
heard him no ever so after I think five
or six weeks we all thought that was
over
and then after about six weeks one
evening before the performance I got a
call at the stage door from Jerry
Robbins a phone call and I'm too nervous
to remember all of it but he said we
liked your test but we like to test you
further
could you get a week's leave of absence
and of course the theater gave me that
so I left London and came to LA for a
week I got to see my family and I met
Bob wise for the first time and I did a
test as Bernardo with a wonderful girl
whose name is Barbara Luna who I think
was a sort of hot contender for the role
of Anita at the time and it was a
fantastic kind of weeks because I got to
be home I got to see Jerry I got to meet
Bob and it was wonderful and then on
Sunday I flew back to London and went
back into this show that felt great
you're just so great to be in the
theater again you know and then those
weeks started to go by and I think after
about 10 weeks I got really Bob wise is
such a lovely man he does things he
doesn't have to do but I got a letter
one day from him a lovely letter saying
we're sorry we haven't let you know
anything he didn't have to do that but
he was kind enough to do it he says but
we haven't cast our Maria and until we
cast on Maria we don't be sure we could
cast Bernardo right um but as it
happened I don't remember how but they
they did cast me for the film before
they cast Maria I suppose just however
things when I that that that was the
very last roll we cast it we ah we were
we were very nervous about making the
right choice for Maria
we tested I I can't remember how many
many girls and and finally we discovered
that we would who was starring at a film
of Elia Kazan's at the time in any event
I we finally decided that that
was the best way for us to go and Maria
completed our and sambal fantastic okay
so then let's see so I came I think they
were already rehearsing about two months
before I got God was able to get there
and so I continued rehearsing with all
of them and I don't know how much later
was that not it came out of the picture
but when I remember the first time I saw
her the reader and I were up on a higher
level rehearsal studio work out probably
on America and I saw this this very
pretty girl that I have just dressed
like anybody else and walking down the
roads probably coming and anyway it was
Natalie and I just remember her so
really so it's not like sort of thing
you're supposed to say okay but I'm not
saying it for that I'm think there's
already mean I thought she was absolute
darling I've been by the way I think you
really picked a fantastic Maria I do all
right not just me but she was darling at
but you know there's we all knew she was
a movie star certainly 23 but she was a
movie star so I think there was a little
bit of that I wish she didn't display or
show any of that but she couldn't help
but feel it at least for me honor I
anyway on so then Natalie was there and
we ended up rehearsing the entire film
before they photographed anything the
first thing was the prologue in New York
so it was kind of like rehearsing a show
at something for the theater we were
everything all the tape marks were on
the floor and the rehearsal room and so
on and we it was it was such a fantastic
time